the footage shows the police officers
unlocking the door with a key and
storming into the apartment
within seconds of a verbal warning 22
year old amel locke lying under a
blanket is dead at an emotional news
conference on friday family members
called for justice and accountability
i believe
that he was executed by the mpd
and i want the police officer
that murdered my son
to be
prosecuted and fired yes
in the video lock can be seen holding a
gun
family members said he had a permit to
carry the weapon
a mirror was a gun
carrying licensed individual
earlier locke's family appeared with
their lawyers in a virtual news
conference
they didn't announce anyone's name
all they all they announced was that
they were there executing a warrant
waking somebody out of sleep while
lawfully possessing a gun the
minneapolis police department has
confirmed that locke's name wasn't on
the warrant
these are wrenching videos to watch
they're painful
but it's necessary
and i hope that it provides some answers
along with the questions the minnesota
gun owners caucus released a blistering
statement criticizing the police saying
mr locke did what many of us might do in
the same confusing circumstances he
reached for a legal means of
self-defense while he sought to
understand what was
happening this latest incident comes
nearly two years after george floyd's
killing by the minneapolis police
sparked international outrage
the department now finds itself at the
center of another controversy a lawyer
for locke's family posed this question
as he called for change the fact that
it's repeatedly
black americans who end up in that
situation
makes us wonder
why isn't it any american why is it only
black americans that we don't give a
chance
to to live in these situations
the minneapolis police department is
being investigated by the justice
department
to see if there's a pattern of civil
rights violations mike hannah al-jazeera
washington